Brasil se ha quedado literalmente en
estado de shock y poco a poco va
recobrando el aliento a medida de que
los campamentos de los bolsonaristas son
desalojados en varias ciudades del país
en Brasilia son han sido necesarios al
menos 40 autobuses para transportar a
los bolsonaristas que todavía seguían
acampados hasta la sede de la Policía
Federal el número Exacto será divulgado
a lo largo del día o tal vez mañana lo
que sí sabemos Es que muchos han llegado
cantando el himno nacional al mismo
tiempo desde las diez de la mañana de
hoy en las principales capitales del
país como Río de Janeiro y San Pablo
también han empezado a desalojarse estos
campamentos que habían sido creados el
día después de las elecciones cuando ya
el bolsonaro fue Derrotado no ha habido
grandes episodios de violencia pero sí
resistencia y como lamentablemente es de
costumbre agresiones a periodistas
Valeria y que otros detalles se conocen
de esta reunión que tuvo Lula con Los
jefes del Congreso y del poder judicial
justamente de donde sale este comunicado
conjunto del que hablábamos hace un
momento
el primer dato es
subrayar que Lula ha decidido despachar
desde edificio del plan alto que ha sido
atacado ayer para mostrar una cierta
fuerza que no se deja digamos ametrar
por los manifestantes el comunicado en
realidad es escueto pide respeto por la
democracia y subraya que el país
necesita diestabilidad de tranquilidad y
llama la población a mantener la paz y a
la democracia de hecho esta tarde se
prevé que en varias ciudades de Brasil
haya manifestaciones de repulsa contra
los actos violentos de ayer sin embargo
entre las filas de los militantes de
izquierda hay una cierta perplexibilidad
porque no hay un acuerdo si es el caso
de salir ahora a las calles o dejarle
foco en los autores de los actos
violentos además se teme que puede haber
enfrentamientos violentos Mientras tanto
Lula esta tarde
con los principales gobernadores de los
27 estados federados de Brasil y una
noticia de última hora Jair bolsonaro
estaría en un hospital en Orlando con
fuertes dolores abdominales